peu
[Musique]
cette année encore c'est noël cette
année encore dans les forêts de ce coin
du monde
des milliers de sapins se sont abattus
sous lâche pour devenir cette sorte de
féerie légère et lumineuse chargé de
paillettes et de lumière et qui reste
dans le souvenir comme le symbole d'une
nuit merveilleux
[Musique]
cette année encore c'est noël cette
année encore de petites mains ont placé
les santons de la crèche fait noël un
nouveau noël à noël pareil à tous les
autres avec des cloches dans le ciel
avec des lumières qui vont vers l'église
par les chemins de nuit comme les
vergers vers l'étoile avec des vitres
ont fui plan avec des yeux émerveillés
et des mains jointes avec cette musique
extraordinaire qui emplit cette nuit là
le coeur des hommes
c'est à saint véran cette année qu'il
faut aller chercher noël à saint véran
dans la montagne
lorsque saint véran et le village le
plus haut de france et k2000 40 mètres
d'altitude on est plus près du ciel
n'est ce pas est un village où il fait
froid ou on est pour ou on est seul
seul dans ces maisons où la même pièce
abrite les gens et les bêtes ou les
seuls événements sont la naissance et la
mort où s'est réfugiée loin des échos de
la vallée la grande simplicité de noël
et parce qu'il y a simplement au milieu
de gens très pauvres
une femme qui berce son enfant et que
peut-être c'est cela surtout noël
[Musique]